[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
justin tucker the ravens kicker joins us
on the program did you sleep last night
justin
uh it took a while to let the adrenaline
subside but i was able to get a couple
hours before my wife and i
got up and uh got our kiddo on the way
to school so
uh
uh you know it's it's all good stuff
though all good what are you thinking on
the sidelines
i'm just uh
hoping to get the opportunity more than
anything and then uh the fact that we
did and then were able to come through
um
you know all of the stuff that goes with
that
that kick at the end of the game i mean
you just first and foremost you want to
you know make the kick and win the game
uh and then
you know as we were lining it up i kind
of realized
that uh
we have a chance to make history right
here this could be pretty special but um
you know all that stuff going into the
kick um
you know all the feelings all the
thoughts all the emotions and i've said
this i've said i know we've talked about
this before dan
um you know i've i've said it before
that uh you know your feelings in those
moments
don't matter what matters is executing
what's what matters is seeing
nick moore
throw
back a perfect strike with the snap 12
o'clock places that sam can just spot
quickly uh you know what matters is
uh the other uh
eight guys
you know just holding their blocks just
long enough to you know help to allow us
to get the ball off in the first place
and then uh just trust in my technique
and when you're that far away you gotta
you know
both trust the technique and also
sacrifice some of it to just power the
ball uh
you know from
from 66 yards away you got to put
everything you can into it so um you
know it's thinking about the process you
know thinking about the action and not
the consequence and then uh when it's
all said and done
then you can let your feelings and your
emotions take over and enjoy the moment
and celebrate with your teammates and
and know that
what just happened
was you know was uh it was was special
it was it was amazing to be a part of it
did you hear the ball hit the crossbar
i did it sounded uh
uh
it said it sounded like what i feel like
my stomach was doing just uh just it
just dropped inside of my
just dropped inside of me and i'm
thinking that
uh i just didn't have enough to get it
there and sure enough it bounced the
right way um you know after
after you know having a couple of joints
in recent memory for myself that didn't
go my way uh to have
that one
yesterday afternoon
uh
work in our favor
is definitely a good feeling where's the
football
it's upstairs right now i just came down
to uh get on this get on this zoom call
with you uh but it's just it's upstairs
right next to my backpack i was holding
on to that thing uh
uh from the moment we uh
you know from the moment we kicked the
ball and one of our uh i said this
yesterday like in our our post-game uh
uh
media
availability we've got a an awesome
group of uh firemen that work in and
around our facilities and they travel
with some of them travel with us on game
days um
but
avon is always down there uh under the
goal posts to you know retrieve the
football and he he didn't even let it
hit the ground uh bounced off the
crossbar
and i knew i knew the kick was good not
after seeing it hit the crossbar um and
then you know kind of fall over but i
saw avon stick
his hands straight in the air and you
know to signal to signal that the kick
was good and then also to catch the ball
so
uh avon did an excellent job of uh you
know not just catching the football but
running it out to me uh to give it to
to give it to me and uh and then i said
yesterday as well uh
yancey one of our other firemen he
prepares the k balls for sundays and
then for us um
throughout the practice week uh
they were like some of the first two
people that are out there on the field
celebrating with us and it it really uh
can't be understated how important
the you know just every every it just
speaks to the importance of everybody
within
our ravens organization you know it
doesn't matter if you're the starting
quarterback or you're you know one of
the firemen helping with the the medial
day-to-day tasks every single one of
those things every single one of those
little details you know
is he preparing the game ball
uh
to
where it is serviceable just serviceable
enough to make it 66 and uh in an eighth
yard when it needed to and then
you know
avon just uh retrieving the ball and
running it out to us uh yeah it just
speaks volumes to you know how our whole
organization operates you know it's not
just one guy it's not just
11 guys it's everybody you know so when
that ball
left my foot it was like the whole
organization it was like the whole city
was was along for the ride and you know
i i i tried not to feel that in the
moment but it's impossible not to after
the fact to just you know really really
enjoy it justin tucker's 66-yarder
eclipse matt prater's 64-yard field goal
back in 2013 is the longest in nfl
history what does the hall of fame ask
for
the ball shoes
they kind of asked i just got off the
phone with uh
chad steele ravens you know media
relations and
he uh he asked me uh
uh
hey the hall of fame is asking for
basically any and everything from the
game that you would like to give them
and i'm having a tough time parting ways
with any of it just because you know
there is some i guess some immediate
sentimental value there but they're
gonna get uh
they're gonna get my uh my uniform from
the game i'm holding on to the ball i
feel like i really wanna keep that and
then uh
uh they they want my cleats too but uh
they're a new pair this week and i tend
to try to make my my cleats last at
least two to three games especially the
the black cleats because they don't show
dirt as much uh so if i can get those
guys to last me like two or three weeks
then you know
maybe maybe our friends in canton they
can have them uh you know maybe like a
month from now but
i mean hey all that stuff is you know
all that stuff is all good and well um
you know i
just uh
i i like if you're if you're gonna try
to get you know every single piece
that went into that one play
on display in canton i don't think it's
possible you know i mean you're gonna
have to take you know
nick moore's arms and sam cook's hands
and
every
single glove of the linemen blocking for
us just to give us a chance you're gonna
i i think you'd have to take sammy
watkins gloves and you know lamar's arm
and you know the the defense just for
you know
you know hanging in there just long
enough to you know get us a
get you know just not giving up a
touchdown at the end of the game
and holding them to a field goal and we
have what 64 seconds left it's
it's just uh
you know
again it's just every single piece
you know that you could think of should
probably
go into the hall along with
you know whatever whatever they want
from from me on maya
if there had been a delay of game
penalty
where there should have been a delay of
game penalty it would have been 71 yards
what would you have said to coach
harbaugh attempting a 71-yard field goal
i don't know if i would have said
anything i probably would have just run
out there anyways and tried to give it a
whirl and
uh
all the while knowing in the back of my
head that i don't think i got
i don't think i quite have 71 in me
today
but um
that's just the type of mentality that
you have to have in a moment like that
you know you just have to let the
adrenaline take over and
uh
hope for a little divine intervention
somewhere along the way but
um
i you know hey man like every everything
kind of happens for some serendipitous
reason right i mean
the the not calling of a delay of game
penalty when it's what like a second
pass o'clock i mean like there's yeah
that i can think of i can think of
plenty of instances where
you know it goes where it goes the other
way you know like when you know another
team gets a break um that you know one
could argue it should not have been
there it just like that that stuff just
that stuff happens in football um
and
you know i i don't i i i
i don't think it takes away from
uh
how special that moment was for all of
us
well congrats there justin and uh good
luck against the broncos i think you
could probably do 71 in denver
i guess we'll have to see that's why i'm
not going to retire the cleats quite yet
you know i think they might have some
more uh they might have some more
yeah uh hey congrats thanks for joining
us we appreciate your time as always
all right thanks dan that's uh justin
tucker raven's kicker